what you did
with the the travel so that people can
travel to
the us
uh with two jabs is also
fantastic
and very welcoming we've been working on
that for a long time but i think the
most important thing today has been your
speech joe to uh to anger
where you've made a commitment on
supporting the world to adapt to climate
change doubling the american
commitment that's uh very important for
us we made a 11.6 billion pound
commitment i mean when i first became a
prime minister but it's it's fantastic
to see the united states really stepping
up and
and showing uh a lead a real real league
and
then of course there's
the progress that we're making in the uh
the defense technology uh partnership uh
that uh that you you've met and uh with
our australian friends
that i think has great potential to
benefit uh the whole of the world and
security
of of the whole of the world so
uh joe thank you for
uh for having us and
um i think you know we're we're boosting
our our shared agenda we want to build
back uh
the world
together with you
and i think we want to renew uh and
strengthen our kinds of languages
and it feels to me like it's it's going
very very well but i think we'll be okay
we just have a couple of questions just
like
just a couple uh
and i think we're gonna be ruthless i'm
gonna be ruthless uh i'm gonna go to
i'm gonna go to harry potter
uh from the sun mr president um
he asked him a question
mr president is uh is britain still at
the back of the queue for a trade deal a
free trade deal as you appreciate the
president obama promises
and may i just ask uh what possible
justification is there for ansa kudas
not to be extradited to the united
kingdom to face justice over the death
of harry
sure thank you thank you one uh that
latter case is being worked on
i was on the impression but i didn't
know this
i was under the impression there had
been
a civil settlement reached but i don't
know that that's true and uh and based
on what i've been told it was
it was not an intentional act it was
someone who's new to
driving on the wrong side of the road uh
quote unquote
and but we're following i'll follow up
on that
i expressed my sympathies when it
occurred
but i don't know the status of that case
right now
the other question was a brexit plea
treatment
is electrical free trail well we're
going to talk about trade a little bit
today
and uh we're gonna have to work that
through let me just stay on on that
harry i mean don't forget folks so we've
we've settled the the uh the the boeing
airbus thing which was a massive problem
uh between us so we're making a lot of
progress to say nothing with the beef
and the whiskey which i already i
already mentioned and just to kind of
say
the whiskey
he's a great ambassador but on on on the
harry dunn
case which is a very very very sad case
everybody's sympathies are with the
family
are very dumb uh i know that the
president has been personally trying to
uh to move things along
and i'm grateful for that i'm to take uh
we're going to take one more question
i'm going to go to
of course
thank you
president um president trump said that
the uk was in front of the queue when it
came to a trade deal you seem to have a
different approach is that because of
your
heritage
your concern about
the irish protocol is that what's
holding it back when it comes to doing
this deal with the uk
there are two separate issues
on the deal with the uk that's
continued to be discussed
but on the protocols i feel very
strongly about those
we spent enormous amount of time and
effort in the united states
it was a major bipartisan effort made
and
i
i would not at all like to see
nor i might add would many of my
republican colleagues like to see
a change in the irish accords at the end
result having a close quarter again
that is absolutely
and
[Music]
we are completely at one and i think
nobody wants to see anything that uh
interrupts or uh unbalances the the
belfast
of course that's the
uh
[Music]